I mean I'm a Suns fan and we've been
dealing with oh the cheapest uh owner in
basketball for the last well I feel bad
for the song experience because they
ain't gonna never get what probably
which I probably deserve
probably to change the mascot what does
that mean
you don't like the gorilla
no bro do you think there's like some
racial connotations with the sun's
gorilla come on bro
and then the thing that's funny is like
they kind of like slick slid that one by
for all these years nobody like
says anything about that well okay
it is random gorillas in the desert they
you can't find anything well that's what
I was gonna say you could probably find
a cactus
or in terms of like the animal chosen
we're in Phoenix it's the Suns I don't
know what they're saying basketball bro
it's just like come on
but you know what's so really crazy
about it
is that it was a um
they just tried it
because they wanted to get some they
want to get the fans involved right
and
that's the reason why they kept it
because the fans loved it but you don't
think it was like Jerry Calandra was
like not purposely trying to I'm just
saying though yeah it's not good
representation because Phoenix is like
the last
City to recognize Dr King as a holiday
man I already know
Phoenix has a gorilla okay we do have
some terrible histories it's just like
how they change the would they change
the Redskins and the Indians to the
commanders yeah I think it's probably
probably about that time as a woke young
black man in America right now
in this climate
I'm surprised Chris Paul hasn't said
anything about it you know what it is
man the sun's gorilla is so popular in
Phoenix yeah I bet it is
I bet it is it's like and that guy and
and the uh mascot is one like mascot of
the year so much yeah and then there's a
wild crazy gorilla he ain't like tamed
or nothing like that no he's a pretty
chill gorilla no well if we're jumping
up off the roof and all that I mean he's
a mascot I've been I'm not I've been
watching it though I'm hip to it yeah
you know what I mean and um
you know at 42 I'm just I'm just looking
at toast that thing's totally different
but I'm 43. I respect it you know what
I'm saying yeah and I'm just saying like
any chance you uh was there any any
discussions where ever thought you might
end up on the Suns no no
it was crazy because when I was playing
this that's something that just just
went over my head
the gorilla yeah like I think I probably
started paying attention to it a little
bit more when I seen um
secret bottle is doing the MCN yeah
shout out to said yeah yeah he was he's
he said is a a great DJ too yeah he is
yeah does radio and [ __ ] he's a legend
in AZ for sure shout out to said and a
Lakers Legend he made all seasons yeah
they didn't make the list though did he
make the list of top 75 list that's
liquor
I'm not sure he's on that you you were
on that right yeah well first of all
congratulations thank you because that's
a big honor to be I mean the most
storied franchise I'd rather have my
number retired
you think that's coming I don't know
[ __ ] I mean
I don't know I mean I feel like I bet
you one thing a home [ __ ] get an
individual award and shoot a reality
show the same season
you know what I'm saying
yeah I shot I was shooting Chloe and
Lamar that year I forgot you guys had
Chloe in the morning I definitely watch
that damn